all right our draft today
teams that we would want to have
full madden franchise mode control over
this off season given all the chaos that
is looming miles you're new to this
morning show draft you're new to the
morning show we do a trivia question to
determine the first pick i have a
question for you
who was the first
player
who graced the cover of the madden game
for years it was john madden they
switched at some point to players who
was the first one that's a good question
um
[Music]
eddie george because i know oh he got it
he got done
you got it
eddie george i know he was on i know it
was him yes there it is eddie george i
you know i have
i have memories now you just download
the game
i remember one time when that game came
out it came out at midnight and my son's
like let's go we went to the mall and
they were giving about pizza and
everything everybody's lined up to get
the madden game i can't remember who was
on the cover that year but it's just an
event every year when that game comes
out and even if nobody buys the box
anymore there's still something to be
said for being on the cover of the game
all right you get it you're up first
what do you got
oh awesome man i'm juiced about that i
yeah that was that made me feel really
good uh let's go with the chargers
that's who do i want because i'll tell
you if you have justin herbert already
that really sets you up very well for
doing whatever else you want to do in
terms of getting guys on your team like
receivers you want to make a trade you
want to do this you want to do that you
also already have joey bosa on your team
and i don't know about you mike but i
like to play with pass rushers so if i'm
gonna get after the quarterback there's
not many people better than playing with
joey bosa also we can talk about
franchise mode you want you have cool
uniforms chargers have some of the best
uniforms in the sport right now and they
play one of the coolest stadiums that's
ever been constructed in the history of
the world so
that's why i would want to play with the
chargers and i want to be the charge gm
i am stunned by your selection for a
variety of reasons
you used to work for the rams
they play in the same stadium you've
already mentioned that the rams could be
one of the super teams i thought that
was going to be your first pick so miles
i'm taking the rams i'm you leaving it
out there i'm taking it and i love i
love
the interior defensive lineman who
throws the center into the legs of the
quarterback and just bull rushes past
him and just screws everything up in
aaron donald he does that at walk
through practices so you got aaron
donald you got jaylen ramsey you're
going to have all these other guys where
you can say hey we got matthew stafford
look at all the buzz i mean think about
it that's the biggest story of the
offseason so far matthew stafford traded
to the rams and everybody thinks it's
going to be this rebirth for the team
and stafford's going to be great so any
skill position players out there who
find themselves available they're going
to come sniffing around the rams and may
and you're going to have your choice
they're going to be lining up for the
chance to play for the rams you
construct a team that was a playoff team
last year you upgraded quarterback you
get all these other pieces you've still
got jaylen ramsey you've still got aaron
donald i i would i would take the rams
and i i'm stunned you got the question
right but you didn't take the team that
i thought would be the obvious first
pick for you well i don't know i think
when you're thinking about franchise
mode you you want something that you can
set up for you know 10 15 years not just
two or three so that's the way i kind of
thought about it but obviously the rims
the rails will be a great choice i still
know people there and maybe i'll hear
from them especially because you called
me out on that uh but i'll go with my
next pick now and i would say my next
pick's gonna be washington and it's for
some of the similar reasons right you
don't have the qb there but you can
figure out a way to get one and i think
you know in franchise mode i don't know
if the player can veto a trade so if
you're washington and you want to give
up three first-round picks and then
whoever else you can find on your roster
to make that thing level out so that
it'll show you a little green bar
instead of the red bar and you can
actually make the trade then hey maybe
you get to sean watson or maybe you you
trade up in order for that number one
pick from the jaguars and then you get
whatever qb that the thing makes up in
there and they're you know user created
whatever it is uh computer system so i
think that would be fun and also you
talk about guys getting after the qb as
a pass rusher you have chase young and i
think he'd be fun to play with and you
can also at least you used to be able to
do the thing where you rebrand the team
so maybe you can actually come up with a
washington football team name i think
that would be fun to do in franchise
mode
i would want to have madden style
franchise mode control this off season
over the green bay packers because i
think that they've been doing it wrong
all due respect they don't play kate
aaron rodgers i would immediately trade
jordan love maybe to your washington
football team
and get assets and go out and
just hey i got aaron rodgers and
i'm going to build my team around him
i'm going to take full advantage of the
opportunity to bring in big name star
players to sprinkle around the roster
and take my 13-3 team and push it to the
next level if i have to say goodbye to
aaron jones i say goodbye to aaron jones
i have to say goodbye to corey linsley i
say goodbye to corey lindsay but i go
out and i grab the guys that i can cheap
contracts one year and try to push it
through the rest of the way and win a
championship at least one more with
aaron rodgers that would be a lot of fun
the
as long as you're on
we're going to get every guy that we can
with an eye toward delivering another
championship for aaron rodgers
okay yeah and that makes a lot of sense
but again i think i think we approach
franchise mode differently here mike
because you're just going all in for one
season and i'm starting to think like
okay how can i make this thing my own
all right so like that's why i think my
next pick would probably be the jets
because
the jets are a completely blank canvas
you can basically do whatever you want
with however you know you want to do
things with sam darnold you trade him
away you get an extra first round pick
if the game actually lets you get a
first round pick form that would be an
interesting thing to do you know then
you still have some maybe some pieces on
defense that you might want to get rid
of
it's all in your control i think if you
want to have the jets and then make them
into a contender in the afc east because
the only team you really got to maybe
contend with is buffalo you know and
then because i don't know how good two
is going to be in that game right so
i think the jets would be interesting
from the sense that they basically are a
blank canvas and you can basically do
whatever you want with them and i would
rather play with them in new york than
with jacksonville and florida sorry
jacksonville
this is a fascinating draft because
we're slipping back and forth from
reality to madden and
and and so i'm gonna slip closer to
madden with this one and say
i would want the ravens because
lamar jackson
is is one of the most deadly weapons
currently in the game and the
quarterback is the guy you control
all the time on offense until you you
know until you hand the ball off or
complete the pass but he's the guy you
control the most he dictates the tempo
and if things break down he can take off
and run build the team around lamar
jackson take advantage of the
opportunities that'll be out there
because look at the struggles they've
had to find receivers
and they've typically had to draft them
because who wants to go join that
offense well this year when the music
stops at the teams that have
the high-flying high-powered passing
offenses there's going to be receivers
left over that's when you can pick the
best ones get the fast ones get the just
get whoever there's going to be guys
there where you can make that team
better you can make that offense more
potent and it's all built around
lamar jackson and a defense it's pretty
damn good and you'll be able to upgrade
them as well and they're already a team
that's on the cusp they make the right
moves this off season whether in real
world or franchise madden mode they're
in a position to be very good in 2021
yeah they probably are and i think that
that's why the ravens are such a
fascinating team and you know when
you're talking about lamar jackson and
playing with mark jackson it's just
there's just so much speed and so if you
kind of really can't throw in that game
like i really just cannot then it makes
it a life a lot easier where you can
just run around and do whatever you want
um i think matt casey makes a good point
wait wait hang on matt casey makes a
good point before your fourth pick
when you sign a free agent in madden the
free agent can't say no so you can go
grab those you can go grab those
receivers even if they don't want to be
blocking all game long all right go
ahead fourth round
okay yeah that's very fair uh next one
so i would go is probably san francisco
the 49ers because you get to decide what
they do with ginny g you can maybe bring
into sean watson get that trade done and
then again you got a bosa on the other
side of the ball where you can have a
lot of fun trying to get after the
quarterback they've got some good
uniforms up there too i kind of think
and you know i think what the the fun
part about the 49ers now is they
definitely are a team that can compete
and
if you make those right trades and you
make those right moves and you're
playing with desean watson
then that makes you an immediate
contender and i think that that would be
a lot of fun to figure out how you get
all those things done and what you can
do with those cornerbacks too you can
maybe sign a good one maybe
you're the miracle that would bring back
richard sherman perhaps so there's a lot
of things that i think make the 49ers a
fun play in franchise mode so just so
i'm clear you would trade jimmy
garoppolo you try to get to sean watson
is that what you would do
absolutely no question
all right uh the next one for me and
this can go a lot of different ways um
i'd i'd be fascinated by the steelers
just because ben see you later
but it's a hell of a lot easier
as the madden gm to find a replacement
the challenge for the steelers is
there's no obvious replacement out there
but you've got the receivers you've got
the defense you're attracted to the pass
rushing
aspect of it tj watt on the team you've
got the back end of the defense you
you're going to be good you get the
right quarterback and you're going to be
great and it's a lot easier as the
madden franchise mode gm to get a better
quarterback than it is in the real world
that's the dilemma the steelers is we'll
be facing if ben isn't there who is
going to take the reins and what's that
going to do to the team in 2021
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports